-Welcome, everybody,
welcome, welcome, welcome
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
I love you!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ah, feels great.
Thank you so much.
Let's get to the news.
Well, guys,
people are still talking
about President Biden's
first press conference
and, by all accounts,
he did well
and there were no major issues.
And, by "no major issues,"
I mean, his dog Major
didn't eat anyone's face.
[ Laughter ]
One of the big moments
from the press conference was
when Biden said he expects
to run for reelection in 2024.
Kamala Harris was like,
"First he puts me in charge
of the border crisis.
Now, this?
Hell of a week."
[ Laughter ]
Listen, I'm not picking sides,
or anything,
but if it's eight years
of falling up airplane stairs
and dog attacks, sign me up!
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Let's do it!
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, Fox News is upset
because Biden didn't call
on them for a question.
-Oh.
-They're so hurt,
this morning,
they did a show called...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, Fox is mad
that they were left out.
It's kind of like your bully
being offended
that he's not invited
to your birthday party.
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
"But I just give you
a wedgie this morning."
[ Laughter ]
But Fox News had a lot of very
fair questions ready to go.
Questions like, "Sir,
how long have you been
a lizard person?"
Stuff like that.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Well --
-[ Laughs ]
-Illuminati joke, yeah.
-Wow. Wow.
-Yeah.
Well, here's some big tech news.
Yesterday, Georgia Republicans
built a time machine
back to 1875.
Check out their new law.
-The bill signed last night
by Republican
Governor Brian Kemp
is seen by critics
as a collection
of voter suppression tactics.
The new law goes so far
as to bar volunteers
from passing out water
and snacks
to voters standing in lines,
lines which are much more likely
to be longer
in Black neighborhoods.
[ Booing ]
-Yeah, the state of Georgia
just passed a new law
that restricts voting, so let's
just say the law is so racist,
it already has its own
warning label on Disney+.
[ Laughter ]
When you heard about the law,
Vladimir Putin was like --
[ As Putin ]
I'm so proud.
They learn
to rig their own elections.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Teach a man to rig,
he will rig for a lifetime.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people are pointing out
how Georgia's governor
signed the bill into law
while he was surrounded
by other white guys.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
They're basically set up
like bowling pins
for Stacey Abrams to knock down.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
That looks like
if the Proud Boys
had a 50-year reunion,
doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, the giant cargo ship
is still stuck in the Suez Canal
-Oh.
-Wow.
-and, every hour, it's delaying
about $400 million worth
of goods.
You know, the captain's
friends are still like,
"No, honestly,
it's not even that bad.
People aren't really
talking about it.
[ Laughter ]
Just stay off the Internet.
Just stay off Twitter.
In fact, stay off of everything
but this phone call, yeah.
No one's really talking
about it."
Meanwhile, every 15 minutes,
the captain's wife is like,
"I told you to get off
at exit 34."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You can't fit.
You can't fit in the thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
First, they tried freeing
the ship with a bulldozer.
Can we take a look
at that picture again?
[ Laughter ]
Now, they're saying
up to 706,000 cubic feet of sand
will have to be removed
to free the ship.
But don't worry,
this kid's on it,
so it's going to be perfect.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We got it.
Hey, listen to this.
A Spirit Airlines flight
from Cleveland to Los Angeles
was diverted
after a passenger tried
to open the emergency
exit door mid-flight.
Don't worry, everyone is fine.
Thankfully,
Spirit always makes sure
their doors are
Flex Sealed shut.
[ Laughter ]
Listen, things like this
are going to happen
when the in-flight movie
is "Mank."
-Yeah.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"I'll take 'Scoob!,'
whatever you got."
[ Laughter ]
Get this --
there was a mystery light show
in the Pacific Northwest
last night
and it turned out to be caused
by something
pretty unexpected.
Check it out.
-At around 9:00,
folks from Seattle to Portland
reported brilliant
blazing streaks overhead.
It turns out they were objects
of debris from a SpaceX rocket
launched a few weeks ago.
-Phew!
It's just careening,
fiery space debris.
[ Laughter ]
For a second, I was nervous.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
some news from Canada.
A police officer pulled someone
over after noticing something
that didn't look quite right.
Watch this.
-Police in Ontario
said an officer
pulled over a motorcyclist
whose license plate was homemade
and also misspelled.
[ Laughter ]
When they took him to jail,
the police were like,
"It's a good thing you like
making license plates."
-Aw.
[ Laughter ]
-At first, he tried
to bribe the police
by handing them a Post-it note
that said "$20" on it.
[ Laughter ]
Then it got even worse
when he handed the officer
his driver's license.
Look. There you go.